Any questions we get will be answered and
they will be in a document that we will link
in the Courses and Webinars page.
I will send out an email and all of that stuff
is ready.
And the ftp site URL, the compressed link
(https://go.usa.gov/xnQ3C) that will get you
to materials, notes for today's demonstrations
and the slides.
We will talk about a program called QuickBLASTP,
this is a program for rapidly finding high-scoring
matches in large databases.
My name is Peter Cooper.
Here is my email address if you have any questions.
The credits for this go to Tom Madden and
Greg Boratyn from the BLAST team.
We will talk about the experiments that have
been done with QuickBLASTP.
We will talk about what it is, we will talk
about why you might want to use it.
We will give a brief description of the algorithm
or procedure that QuickBLASTP uses, enough
so you can understand what it does.
We will look at some of the experiments that
Tom did looking at results and comparing them
to ordinary blast and we will talk about how
to get to QuickBLASTP on the website and how
to use the standalone binary that you can
get to now as a demonstration.
Then we will have some live demonstrations
on the web and on the command line.
What is QuickBLASTP, this is a faster alternative
for ordinary protein protein blast.
It uses a specially pre-indexed database.
It is designed for rapid matching of queries
and very similar database sequences.
About 97% of the database sequences with 70%
or more identity to query are found.
And 98% of the database sequences with 80%
This is compared to what you would get with
ordinary BLASTp, so it is less sensitive.
Why do we need this?
There are challenges that are the result of
the advent of high throughput sequencing and
processing of genomes.
The default database, nr, now contains greater
than 141 million sequences.
It also has 51 billion letters.
The doubling time is two years.
Many of you have experienced the fact that
ordinary protein blast searches are taking
longer than they used to.
If you have a highly represented protein,
one with lots of copies in the database, a
search can take a few minutes.
Modern projects generate large numbers of
protein sequences and they need to analyze
a lot of the protein coding regions and what
you're trying to do, maybe you have a metagenome
or genomic sequence, is find the strong matches
in the database, because many of those proteins
will have strong matches.
We need a process to let you quickly identify
strong matches to a set of query sequences.
Sensitivity is less important.
This is an oversimplified description of QuickBLASTP.
The first part of the search, uses an alignment
free method.
It makes an index of the five-mers of the
database and the query sequences and looks
them up in memory to find candidate matches
with good k-mer content compatibility.
The second part is to take those candidate
matches to do a blast alignment.
Doing that means you get a standard blastp
alignment and statistics.
The first part uses an alignment free method.
Here are some results that Tom in the group
presented at the NIH Research Festival recently.
They are the kinds of things we are talking
about.
THey looked at a proteome of Chigell flexneri.
This has 4799 proteins from a whole genome
shotgun assembly project.
And another kind of proteome, from a transcriptome
shotgun assembly project for a tick, Amblyomma
sculptum, and 4246 proteins.
Basically they did searches comparing those
against the protein nr database.
They got information from that about how blastp
and kblastp perform.
Kblatp is the name of the standalone program
that corresponds to QuickBLASTP.
For BLASTp, the Shigella took 10 hours.
And for Amblyomma it took 18 hours.
In the corresponding cases QuickBLASTP, the
faster method, reduced the time by a tremendous
amount.
The speedup for Shigella was 13 times faster.
And for Amblyomma it was about 20 times faster.
This is a huge improvement in the speed in
which you can analyze a set of proteins.
This is looking at the number of hits found
at various percent identities.
As you go down in percent identity, kBLASTp
does worse compared to BLASTp.
The little circle is the 65% identity point
and that is a good point to say, below that
percent identity, QuickBLASTp is not as effective.
For this set of proteins, it is not as dramatic
as it is for the next set.
These are the ones from the tick.
You can see below 65% identity these depart
quite a bit.
This has to do with what kinds of proteins
are in the database and how closely related
they are to the proteins we are working with.
You see less saturation of BLASTp results
with the tick proteins than with the Shigella
proteins.
Another way to look at this, is to look at
the number of missed hits compared to BLASTp
with a 65% identity cutoff and without one.
You see fewer missed hits.
The blue column is for zero missed hits.
There's a slight difference in the 65% (orange)
bar.
There's more difference if you look at that
for the tick proteins.
The take away is that this works well but
is only limited to things that are better
than 65% identity which is fine, if you are
trying to find out which protein is this in
the database.
How can you run QuickBLASTP or kBLASTp?
Smart blast has been around for a number of
years uses the QuickBLASTP algorithm already.
QuickBLASTP is on the protein protein BLAST
page.
KBLASTp is available as a stand-alone demonstration
package on the FTP area.
In terms of the website, smart blast is linked
directly on the homepage.
It uses the QuickBLASTP algorithm.
If you want to know more about smart blast
we did a webinar on that a while back.
That link will take you to our YouTube channel.
This is the standard protein protein BLAST
page, you can see one of the program selections
is now the QuickBLASTP.
BLASTP is the default but you can change this
to QuickBLASTP.
Right now this is only available for the nr
database.
It requires a special index of those five
Mers of the database.
You can also download a Linux package for
this, quickblastp.tar.gz.
This is available in the demo area of the
blast FTP area.
There is a README and a tar ball there.
We also have the indexing program as well.
The README tells you exactly how to download
and install this.
It comes with several different programs.
This right now is only available for Linux.
You get kBLASTp which is the corresponding
standalone version of QuickBLASTP.
It does the first part and the second part
of the search.
It has very similar options to BLASTp.
There is the mkkblastindex, this is the program
that makes the database index, it requires
a formatted protein database as input and
it will add additional indices for the initital
alignment.
The package also comes with the update_blastdb.pl
Perl script for downloading your blast databases.
There is also a script called catvolumes.sh
that loads the database into memory and you
can get a hot start on your search.
It speeds up the search if you have a large
database.
It specifies the refseq_protein database,
but you can modify this to use other databases.
A couple of things to think about, we have
said this but I want to remind you, QuickBLASTP
rapidly finds closely related proteins.
It is not terribly useful if the matches are
below 65% identity.
It is best used for batches of queries.
Maybe smaller numbers on the web, but still
useful.
The standalone program, kBLASTp.
For this to work it requires that the database
plus the indices be completely loaded into
RAM.
For the default nr database, the database
plus the indices require 200 to 250 GB of
RAM.
The index files occupy more than half of this
total.
You need a machine with lots of available
RAM to do this effectively.
I will leave this slideshow now.
I will do a couple of demos, one the web.
I will show you what happens when you do a
protein blast and QuickBLASTP with the same
set of proteins and the same settings.
I will take five proteins from the Shigella
proteomes.
And then I will show you some sensitivity
limitations.
I took some of those tick proteins which have
less good matches in the database and you
can see what happens when you get below 50%
identity.
Then we will go to the command line and do
some kBLASTp searches with 33 proteins from
a plasmid from Serratia liquefaciens
I'm going to do two things here.
Let me make this a lttle big bigger.
I will use these notes.
These are from the demos and they are available
on the FTP site.
And these RIDs are preserved so these links
to the searches will work.
I will go ahead and show you the speed with
these five Shigella proteins.
I will select them.
I will copy these.
I will go over to the protein search page.
And I will paste them in.
Okay.
They are ready to go.
By default, the settings are to run blastp.
I will start that blastp search running and
I will open my results in a new tab, and I
will change a couple of things.
I will set 500 hits.
And I will set the Evalue cutoff to ten to
the minus 6.
I will start that running.
It is loading in this tab.
This is my blastp search.
Let's go back and I will change this to QuickBLASTP.
It changed my Max target sequences.
I want to have 500.
I will run that.
This is where it gets interesting.
We can watch the time since submission.
My experience with this is that it takes about
10 seconds.
Let's see if that is true.
Yes.
Pretty much.
About 10 seconds.
Meanwhile the blastp search is still running.
With an organism like Shigella, there are
lots of proteins in the database that are
very similar to the ones we are working with.
This search has worked pretty well.
You can go and look at the results.
We have a lot of hits.
Here is one that did not get a lot of hits.
If we look at the scores, I hit a Shigella
protein, it has a good coverage and 100% identical
with the same protein.
It says your search has less than 10 matches.
You may want to run the search with BLASTp.
This is probably the right answer, but you
can go back and try that again.
I will show you a case now where the results
you get with the QuickBLASTP is probably not
the right answer.
My BLASTp results came in.
I can take a look.
I did get one other hit, but a weaker one.
This is probably okay.
There is a hit at 51% identity that I don't
get wtih QuickBLASTP.
I will show you another example where you
have to watch out.
So, that is when you get down into lower percent
identities.
This is from the Amblyomma sculptum transcriptome.
I'll get the QuickBLASTP results here.
I will open this up into one of these tabs.
These were four different proteins.
I can show you what they were.
I got those from that transcriptome and I
ran the search with them.
The first one looks fine, lots of good matches.
I want to show you the last protein.
It finds one hit and notice my identity is
low, 27%.
This is something I would not want to think
about in terms of using this as a result because
it is too low for quick blastP to be useful.
Just to show you the difference, I will go
ahead and load the BLASTp results.
I will copy this.
And I will paste this in the same window.
Let's look at the last protein again.
Remember, this protein was one match with
kblastp, this finds a lot of good matches.
They are highly significant when you are using
BLASTp.
Be careful when looking at a low percent identity,
you really don't want to be using quickblastp.
It works great if the sequences are very similar
to each other, or they have a lot of examples
of each other in the database is maybe another
way to put that.
The next thing I want to do is to go and show
you the standalone package.
If you go to the notes, it has the setup commands,
and I have already done those.
So I downloaded QuickBLASTP and I downloaded
the swissprot database because it is small
and we can run searches relatively fast.
This is the command that you would use to
index your database.
I will not run that for you because it takes
a couple of minutes.
Let's go ahead and we will do a search.
As a bonus example, I will show you how to
use elink to get the protein sequences for
this Serratis plasmid.
Let me put in the command.
This says I will get the accession of that
plasmid from the nucleotide database and go
to the protein database and fetch the FASTA.
Let's do that first.
I will go to a command window here.
Let's run that.
This should only take a few seconds.
Okay.
I want to make sure that really worked.
I have a lot of proteins.
Now I have a couple of command lines, one
for kBLASTp and one for BLASTp.
I will run them under the Unix command, time,
so we can see how long they take.
Here is kBLASTp and the command.
This command line, it wrapped a little bit,
but the options are no different than for
an ordinary BLASTp.
I have selected my database.
I have the query and I have a Evalue cutoff
of 10 to the minus 6.
I have the tab delimited output format 7,
and I will make an output file here.
Time will tell me how long it takes to run.
It usually takes about 10 seconds or so.
Let's see how it goes.
How long it takes depends on the machine you
are using and what is going on on that machine
and things like that.
So the real time was about nine seconds.
Let's make sure that wasn't the trick.
Let's check.
Let's look at the output file.
We have a lot of stuff.
There are a lot of records.
It is a big file.
I will start the BLASTp running.
The same query, same commandline basically,
but a different program.
That will run for a little while.
While we are doing that, I will point out
where you can get some additional information.
Let's go ahead and run this.
A reminder, here is the BLAST homepage.
It has its own special URL, blast.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
And there is a help link at the top.
It takes you to a page that has lots of documentation.
There is a news feed and a mailing list that
you can subscribe to.
Tao and I sit on the blast-help email aliase.
You can write to us anytime you have a question.
It is a good idea to send us your RID if you
have a problem so we can see what happened.
Here are additional links.
There is a BLAST help book that has several
different parts including how to set up blast,
the standalone, command line manual.
There are general things that you should know
about.
We have a blog.
We have a YouTube channel.
We have a support center, you can go here
if you have a question and maybe you can find
the answer there.
If you cannot, send us an email.
There's also a set of factsheets on our ftp
site.
Many of them are about BLAST.
Tao is the major contributor to that.
There are a lot of things about how to set
up BLAST.
Let's see if that has finished.
It is still running.
It just finished.
It took about two minutes.
That is all I have to talk about today.
Any questions?
If you think of anything, please email us.
If you have a question about the webinar program
in general, please write to, webinars@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
Thank you for coming.
We will see you next time.
>> [ Event concluded ]